thank you for rejoining us on channel 8
earlier you heard from governor sislek
in what was his second state of the
state address
covering a wide variety of issues
important in nevadans
that's for sure brian of course talked
about the budget getting kids back to
school creating thousands of jobs and
what his hopes are for nevada moving
forward
so now let's hear the rebuttal from
republican nevada assemblyman the caucus
leader
dr robin titus hello i'm dr robin titus
the assembly republican leader
delivering this response to governor
sisilak's state of the state message
i'm addressing you at the foothills of
the stunning sierra nevada mountains
and douglas county socially distanced i
would also like to thank those who are
always so close in our hearts and minds
our military and our veterans nevada is
committed to our military
we strive to be the most veteran
friendly state in the nation
and as a wife of a former sheriff i also
extend a special thank you
to all law enforcement and first
responders on behalf of all nevadans
thank you for serving our communities
and our state
2020 has been a contentious and
challenging
year for nevadans we have adapted and
bravely met challenges thrown our way
in the battleborn state remains
resilient this past year has brought
stories of loss despair
and heartbreak while tales of neighborly
love support
and humanity offer solace and buoyancy
everyday heroes emerge from our
communities even when
the virus was barely understood as a
seasoned family practice doctor
i'm still amazed by the bravery of
healthcare workers
and first responders putting their own
lives at risk exposing themselves to the
virus every day just to take care of the
rest of us
we owe our gratitude to the grocery
store workers keeping our shelves
stocked
the farmers and ranchers keeping food on
our tables the gas station attendants
and truck drivers
and postmen and women who keep
delivering the volunteers who helped
work at food
banks and donated their time money and
effort
to help our vulnerable populations and
so many others
for the sheer innovation and
perseverance of everyday people
we have survived today i will discuss
our priorities of immunizing
and improving health care access across
nevada prioritizing our children's
education
rebuilding our economy maintain open and
transparent government
and enacting meaningful election reform
the covet 19 pandemic exposed the fault
lines of our health care system
this is allowing us to implement
commonsense reforms
that will provide equitable and
accessible health care to all nevadans
we are lucky to have the best of the
best health care professionals
in the nation and are proud to see how
they have kept
nevadans safe and healthy however
we simply do not have enough a recent
study by the university of nevada
and the american association of medical
colleges shows nevada ranks 48th
in the country for the number of primary
care physicians per hundred thousand
people
we must expand our health care workforce
to provide efficient
and affordable health care to all
communities that's why republicans will
continue to bring forth
solutions that keep our doctors in
nevada by removing burden regulations
and creating
incentives for new doctors our medical
professionals should be given the same
benefits of protection from civil
liability
that we offer our business community
they deserve this for risking their own
well-being to put patients
first during the pandemic our healthcare
crisis goes beyond the pandemic itself
opioid abuse and mental health problems
continue to devastate the lives of many
nevadans
we can't ignore these issues but we also
shouldn't exacerbate the problem through
restrictive policies
education is the most important
foundation for bettering the lives of
every nevada child
who all deserve the opportunity of a
quality education
however due to the covet 19 pandemic and
our efforts to keep nevada families safe
education priorities were disrupted to
to prevent kids falling further behind
a herculean effort was undertaken by
connecting kids nevada
to provide reliable internet access to
students across the state
through the public-private partnership
nearly half a million students
across all state counties now have
internet access
our efforts to respond quickly through
remote learning
are a short-term solution and if we are
to minimize the
achievement gap we must get our kids
back in the classroom
the lack of continuity and uncertainty
has led parents to explore options that
better fit their kids learning
experience
we strongly believe that zip codes
should not determine
life outcome and a one size fits all
policy
is hurtful our education system can rise
to the occasion and give families
options so they can find an education
that best fits their needs
kids should not be trapped in failing
schools
the pandemic has demonstrated just how
valuable good teachers are
to society and we need to have
incentives and compensation
to reward them education doesn't end at
high school or college
skilled workforce training and higher
and technical education
options are the foundation of providing
well-paying careers
in both urban and rural areas as more
companies continue
making nevada their home we must ensure
we are training for the jobs of tomorrow
workforce development and investment is
critical for nevada to be competitive
mining provides some of the best-paying
jobs in the state and not only in rural
nevada
to broaden awareness of the industry
mining is partnering with workforce
development agencies to ensure that all
nevadans are aware
of the many career opportunities
available to them as well as partnership
with groups like first nevada that are
helping young students prepare for the
emerging
emerging science technology engineering
and mathematics
stem jobs finding an equitable and
balanced solution that protects our
vulnerable populations
and gives nevadans the right to work and
provides for their families is a
challenge we still struggle with today
the state of nevada once had the fastest
growing economy in the country
then the coven 19 pandemic hit and
created both a health and economic
crisis
our understanding of the virus has come
a long way since the initial two-week
shutdown
when our state and nation tried to slow
the spread and flatten the curve
nearly a year ago it is necessary to
keep our state open for business and to
get
unemployed or underemployed people back
to work
we must safeguard livelihoods by using
our knowledge of spread mitigation
and workforce vaccine integration we
have to protect
existing industries like mining and
tourism through sound
policies that encourage innovation and
spur job growth
mining is a bedrock of our economy and
we are proud to have
some of the safest and most
environmentally responsible
mining operators in the world our
tourism industry
sees millions of visitors a year and
provides good paying jobs to thousands
of nevadans the silver state has led the
nation
in gaming's regulatory framework and the
innovation
exhibited by the industry we must resist
effort to raise taxes on the backs of
businesses
attempting to manipulate the nevada's
complex tax structure via ballot
initiatives
is both irresponsible and short-sighted
and will hurt nevada families
since mid-march when businesses were
ordered shut down
unemployment systems started to fail
thousands of nevadans
worsening fight their financial
instability
the first round of blanket restrictions
in the spring
had devastating impact on nevada's
infrastructure and this is still felt
today
theater's unemployment system was
inefficient and insecure
as a result between a hundred thirty
three thousand and a hundred eighty five
thousand fraudulent jobless claims were
filed
which cost taxpayers millions of dollars
a recent study found that sixty percent
of business
closures due to coven 19 are permanent
harsher restrictions will once again
cause declining sales and
revenue for local businesses and
increase unemployment
our state cannot afford this any blanket
government shutdown
is not sustainable and threatens the
livelihood of many nevadans still trying
to recover from the first mandatory
shutdown
employers and businesses play an
important role in our communities
we need to continue focusing resources
in growing business and creating jobs
without
overbearing government interference in a
safe and responsible manner
we will always fight for a tax friendly
business environment to attract new and
innovative
high-paying permanent jobs to our state
and promote small business growth
from aerospace information technology
manufacturing
and logistics energy and other emerging
industries
nevada should continue to provide
opportunities for those with a dream
talent and work ethic to achieve
we saw the limitations our state faced
as it responded to the crisis
the challenges needed to keep our
economy going
and to keep our people safe were evident
from draconian policies that
decimated our private sector to the
mismanagement of government agencies
that failed to provide individuals
with much needed resources we saw areas
that need improvement
we believe in an effective and
accountable government that will work in
coordination with the private sector to
provide a working framework
and remain answerable to nevadans that
includes a budget process that
prioritizes transparency
accountability and open communication
between community
and industry leaders checks and balances
among the three branches of the
government are essential for transparent
and collaborative government
unilateral laws that bypass legislative
bodies
create restrictive policies that only
further damage our
already struggling economy republicans
will continue to fight for limited
government
individual liberty and policies that
will allow our businesses to thrive and
our citizens to earn a living
during the upcoming legislative session
we must reign in the overreach of our
state government
and safeguard it individual liberty
confidence in our electoral integrity
has reached an all-time
low this is troubling because voting is
a
pressure relief valve that maintains
stability
and peace in a democracy by keeping
politicians accountable
but for it to work the citizenry must
trust
only legitimate votes are counted votes
are the currency of our
democratic republic and must be
respected
every nevadan who casts a ballot
deserves assurance
that their vote will not be nullified by
a fraudulently cast vote
that's why republicans are pushing a
slate of new bills to restore electoral
confidence in the silver state
democratic process
state legislatures are the proper
vehicle to address the loss of electoral
trust
and we must work in a bipartisan way to
enact election reform all eyes were on
nevada's ballot processing
that dragged on long after polls had
closed
we must study states who excelled at
secure processing
and tabulation florida haunted by the
presidential election of 2000
processed over 11 million votes in four
hours
and enabled the associated press to call
the state of florida for president trump
at half an hour past midnight on
election night
this is the standard we must emulate
this year
we will be conducting redistricting it
is our duty to give the public a fair
and transparent process to void a
special interest
and gerrymandering constituents of all
legislative districts
deserve a seat at the table this year
as elected representatives and civic
leaders in nevada
now more than ever we shall resolve to
conduct ourselves
better than what we see in washington to
leave the paralyzing
hyper partisanship at the door and to
work together
across the aisle not as democrats and
republicans but as americans and
nevadans
we must return to civil debate and open
an honest discourse
which is a foundation of good governance
together
let us lead by example and conduct
ourselves with
honor respect and dignity lastly i would
like to honor two nevadans that recently
passed away
nevada business titan sheldon adelson
and judge stephen elliott
they will truly be missed our
condolences to mary maddison
and mindy elliott may god bless you
may god bless our men and women in
uniform may god bless america
and may god bless the great state of
nevada
may god keep us healthy unified and
prosperous
thank you and stay strong